[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show and it's where america is hanging
out to have a conversation about life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
best-selling author soon to be
multi-best-selling author christy wright
today is the day she joins us on a very
very busy day and a very important day
for all of us at ramsey solution it is
launch day of her brand new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance so we're here together to
take your calls if you're feeling
squeezed you feel like you just can't
spin another plate this is the hour to
call in it's a free phone call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five of course we'll take your money
questions we'll take your questions
about making more money we'll take your
questions about moving up advancing
starting something uh it's it is open
season uh but i just know that uh this
issue christy um more so than ever
because of access to digital all the
technology that's supposed to make our
life easier feels like it's just making
it crazier it is and it's interesting
because one of the things i've i've told
people is i've been a certified business
coach for over a decade and the number
one question i'm asked through my
coaching through speaking events you
know whatever
is not a business question it's this
question and i'm asked it by men and
women those with kids without kids kids
of all ages single it doesn't matter we
all struggle with feeling like we don't
have enough time i just need more time i
just need more time i just need to be
more productive more efficient i need to
multitask better i need a better app i
need a better morning routine i'm going
to wake up earlier stay to play
we try all that and we're exhausted ken
and we don't feel any more balanced and
so i wanted to tackle this issue
that's a major pain point for everyone i
know first of all but also it's a pain
point in my own life with three little
kids like i get it and i think that the
the solution is something different than
more productivity and more efficiency i
think that we have a root
issue going on um and i think we need to
tackle it there if we're gonna solve the
problem from coming up again and again
in the same way and so that's why i love
the tagline the guilt-free guide to life
balance so many people
walk around every day feeling like
they're failing and they're not and so i
want to help him there as i've talked to
you about the book watching you write it
watching you develop the content over
time speaking about it coaching folks
feels like to me
that it's it's really about priority we
have so much hard time deciding between
priorities i think this book gives the
back story it gives the foundation for
what really is the problem it's not time
management yes well and the way that i
say it is this is not just about the
calendar it's about enjoying the life
that the calendar represents and so um
to your point so so a lot of people that
i work with are women and a lot of
people i work with are creatives this
book is not just for women and creatives
by any means but i think one thing that
that those two groups of people have in
common
or really anyone that has a lot of
interests multi-interested people
is we tend to treat everything as if
it's created equally and so our to-do
list our calendar we can't make
decisions between a yes here and a no
there because it all feels equally
important and it's not uh you know is it
petroglyn trinity that said if
everything's important nothing is and so
i don't tell you in this book what is
important but i do what i believe good
coaches do which i ask you a lot of
questions that bring that awareness to
you for yourself for you to decide hey
here's what matters to me in the season
and then i show you tactical steps to
align your time with those things and it
turns out that when you do the right
things at the right time you actually
feel that sense of balance that you've
been looking for but i want to help you
discern
what really matters right now
from all the other junk that's coming at
you all the time because we all have a
lot of stuff coming at us and i want to
help you sift through that
and discern what's most important so you
can spend time on those things she is
christie wright i'm ken coleman with
ramsey personalities and we are your
hosts this hour here on the ramsay show
the new book that we're talking about is
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance it hits the market today
in fact nut hits it's already out there
it's going and uh of course ramsay
solutions.com everywhere books are sold
can i tell you something exciting
this is very exciting it's at target oh
yeah i heard it
high five on the air because tyler your
brand leader told me this this is a big
deal so let me just say this this is
very exciting head to target your local
neighborhood target to get christy
wright's book take back your time this
is huge because people may not realize
this but it's very hard to get in target
target is also my target market one of
my favorite stores and i haven't been
able to talk about it all have you been
to your local target yes this morning
first thing and i screamed and ran did
you buy all the copies no but i did
i did sign them so if you're in
nashville i'll tell you about the target
that's fine but this lady was walking by
when i was in the parking lot and i was
screaming at target and she walked by
she said i've never seen anyone so
excited to go and target in my life yeah
well
let me tell you why ma'am
i know
it's a huge win it's a huge deal i've
had to keep it top secret until today
but if you go to your local target it's
on an end cap
right there in the book section and man
that just felt like a huge
i'm gonna i don't know if i need to run
by target tonight james but if i might
uh ask stacey on the way home babe you
need me to pick anything up and i'll
head on over there and uh maybe i'll
pose beside the end cap there it is you
should have bought every copy
and then stood in line at the register
and everybody that came by goes hey i'm
just gonna bless you with this
just cause it causes a scene a little
bit of a fun scene that's really
exciting yeah so anywhere books are sold
but yeah we were pretty excited because
today's the first day i can announce
that it is in targets all over the
country and so you can go get your copy
today and uh and and if you do you know
tag me on social media i'd love to share
it at chris tv right it's just fun to
celebrate that that's a big deal people
may not realize it but that's a big deal
that's a huge deal um i want to stay in
the content for just a second because i
think
something you said a minute ago i think
makes me ask the question
is
one of the root causes of the stuff
you're taking on in this book
take back your time is it that we just
have a hard time
displeasing somebody when in all reality
we're not displeasing them but we think
we got to do this we think we got to do
this we think we got to do this we think
we got to do this and it's at some point
it's like there's only so much you can
do and i keep you you've got this i
think the bumper sticker amazing truth
in this entire book which is chock full
of wisdom and knowledge
is doing the right thing at the right
time and i think that we struggle with
that as humans yes we do what's
interesting is why it's multifaceted
it's not just one thing like oh if i
solve this one variable this will fix
all my problems because there's actually
several factors at play so for example
let's just talk about the people
policing aspect of it and many people
struggle with this they struggle with
saying i think that's a huge problem we
don't want to you know we want to be
liked and all that well there's the one
element of okay let's look at one facet
one facet is we really do want to help
we really do want to help people so
someone needs us we want to help there's
that one obvious piece the second piece
of it if you're if you're a person of
faith then you feel called to help you
feel like hey i've got to help i'm
commanded to help so there's this deeper
you know faith aspect of it
the third one that i think that we don't
talk about enough or even are willing to
acknowledge enough and i hit on this in
the book
is there is a
there is an aspect of our own insecurity
that drives us to do things and say yes
to things that are not right for us
not because we're just so loving and
helpful even though that is a piece of
it but because we are trying to earn our
place in the world we are trying to beat
enough we we think we are our calendar
our to-do list our productivity and so i
heard someone say
years ago there's a difference between
doing something to be loving and doing
it to be loved
and if we're willing to get honest with
ourselves that's good some of us are
trying to earn love because it's a deep
insecurity in us but what i tell people
is
the black hole of insecurity can't be
fixed by just doing more you've got to
solve this at the root issue no amount
of task on your to-do list is going to
fix it wow that's good folks
the motive all right the new book is
take back your time the guilt free guide
to life balance available wherever books
are sold but especially on the end cap
at your neighborhood target go get it
for chrissy wright but more importantly
get it for you don't move your calls
coming up this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my co-host and
colleague christy wright she is the
best-selling author of business boutique
and now
soon to be the best-selling author of
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance it's launch day so i'm
going to talk about it a lot if you
don't like it i'm sorry that i'm talking
about good things
um if you don't want to hear i'm sorry
you don't want to be happy i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry you don't want to grow
you don't want to be
successful i'm sorry
i'm going to talk about good things i
don't apologize on the ken coleman show
when i talk about good things
i'm not going to apologize here but
anyway we're very excited as a company
congratulations my friend thank you
thank you very very exciting day but we
are here for you triple eight eight two
five five two two five the questions
that you've come to know and to listen
to you can ask for yourself chris and i
are gonna help you we enjoy being
together uh you got two coaches so let's
go triple eight eight two five
825-5225 let's start it off in miami
florida nestor is there nestor how can
we help
hi ken how's it going um thank you guys
so much for taking my call
um so my my question for you guys is um
right now i'm i'm getting married i'm
planning to get married in october um
and so far um everything's been set and
so um i'm wondering uh because i come to
work about an hour and so i spend a lot
on gas and on tolls um and uh but the
only kind of down or upside is that you
know like in the field that i'm in i'm
in the mental health field um at my job
there's a lot of growth opportunities
and so i'm wondering should i try to
find something better that has like
better growth opportunities closer to
home or should i um just stay where i'm
at and kind of like reap the benefits of
all that i think it's
i think it's either or i think whatever
door opens here i mean this is not to me
a choice between one or the other it's
sure look for something closer to where
you're going to be living
and if you can find a better ladder than
you currently have great take it but
you're also in a place right now where
you have a nice ladder there's plenty of
opportunity for growth where you are so
i wouldn't be antsy uh i i got to tell
you now this is me i like christy
weighing on this but a lot of this to be
honest with you this is just ken coleman
personal preference so don't take this
as advice i'm just going to tell you how
i'm wired if i'm in a place
where i've got a ladder of opportunity
as you have stated
and it's in the field i want to be in
and it's about the commute and i get to
choose where i want to live ultimately
i'm going to do everything i can to move
a little bit closer you're starting out
a new chapter of life i don't know if
your bride-to-be is open to this but i'm
just telling you that's what i would be
considering first and foremost however
i'd always be looking always be looking
you know i mean i tell people in the ken
coleman all the time you know i get this
call a lot christie hey ken i've been
with this company two years they've been
really really good to me um i've had a
good opportunity here but i got another
opportunity that's better but i feel bad
i feel bad absolutely you know you
shouldn't feel bad you don't even feel
bad yeah i mean you don't break a
contract don't do anything that's not
full of integrity and character but the
reality is why
should you feel bad about taking a great
opportunity for yourself so that's my
take on it nestor christy anything you'd
add to that yeah no what i love about
your question nestor is you have
a few good options that's a great call i
i get discouraged when we get the calls
of like hey i hate my job i hate my boss
i need the paycheck you're kind of feel
a little painted in a corner and you're
trying to you're trying to get out
quickly you're not trying to get out
quickly it's great to keep your options
open look around you could look to move
or look for jobs closer to you or you
could stay where you are and make the
commute you just you have great options
and that's a really good place to be
yeah so take the best option again you
know research research research always
be looking always be considering always
be measuring and weighing and i think
you're going to make a great choice by
the way congratulations on the yeah
upcoming nuptials by the way there's a
word we don't say enough no
i love a good word and the word
nuptials you love a good unused word i
like to bring some words i like to dust
off a good word
there it is boise idaho is where we go
next michael is there michael how can we
help
hey ken and kristy thanks for taking my
call sir um i
uh just had a annual review of my work
and it went really well but my raise
wasn't quite where i wanted to be um or
where it really needs to be so i'm i'm
feeling kind of underpaid for the
industry um and so i want to go to my
boss and
uh you know negotiate a raise with him
but i'm not really sure the best way to
do it i had kind of two two ways in mind
as one of your opinion on which which
way you think would sort of go over
better um yeah hit me with a quick
summary yeah give us uh the two ideas
you had and give us the quick version
and we'll weigh in on it
okay so the first one i thought was
really um
just going to him explaining why i need
to make more why i think i should be
making more and working on him on how i
can get there what needs to be done um
which the reason i don't really want to
do that is because it kind of feels like
it puts me in a corner where then either
if he says no then i'm kind of like well
it sort of sours that working
relationship and then i'm i'm kind of
it's
awkward so michael the way the reason
you feel that way is because you're
feeling is absolutely right that we're
gonna go ahead and kill idea number one
that's awful
it puts you in a corner the way you
chose to say that is absolutely right so
that's not a good option what's the
second one
so the other option is there's there's
lots of hiring um in my field in the
area and they're paying anywhere from
six to eight dollars more an hour um and
so i was my other option was to go and
actually apply for those interview if i
need to and see if i get any offer
letters and then once i have an offer
letter go back to them and say hey
i have an offer from this other company
here's what they're paying
you know before i go work for them can
you match that yeah i i don't mind that
option at all
but i would just add a my own option a
since we struck your a
um and that's this you just recently had
the meeting
uh how long ago was it we're talking 48
hours a week
about you about two weeks ago
okay
um three weeks ago i would have
preferred for you to sat on you know to
sit on it for about you know two nights
max
i i would have in that situation you can
still do this go back in and go hey
listen uh i'm really grateful for the
bump because you did get a bump you just
didn't get the bump that you wanted ten
percent yeah yep so i go back in and go
hey listen thank you for the bump
um i'm grateful to be here because i
think that's true i want to be here long
term i did some homework because when
you gave me the bump i didn't want to
assume anything so i went did some
homework and i would present the
homework at that time i would present
and this has got to be this isn't like a
couple comments uh in the comments
section of glassdoor this is real market
research
that shows someone of your experience
and your position what the market is
bearing
and you would need to sit down and show
them that go listen because you gave me
the bump i'm appreciative but i went and
looked at it and i because i was curious
and this is where i sit
based on what i do
and the experience level i bring the
table
um
would you be willing to take it up to
this point because i feel like
um i feel like that's something that you
should at least consider you're humble
about it you just go hey would you
consider not don't say what i just said
sorry i was formulated just say look i
would i would ask you to consider this
information i've done the research
on what someone someone gets i am
grateful for what you gave me
but i would like to be in this range see
what you're saying there is i would like
there's no demand there's no i deserve i
should let's remove any of that language
because what you don't want to do is put
your leader on the defensive you want
your leader to go oh uh michael's uh a
very well informed person and went and
looked and uh you know what he gave me
something to think about and then it's
almost like what can i do to get to this
number because here's why you're doing
this michael
you want to see
where the leader's position is
on paying you that comp do they think
that you
uh
in their mind deserve what the market
says you should be getting i want to
know that i want to know where i stand
well and one of the things i would i
would jump in here ken one of the things
i learned from you years ago even but
you may not remember this even before
you worked on our team here at ramsay
you did a devotional for us but you
talked about the importance of asking
questions and michael when you ask
questions i learned this straight from
ken coleman right beside me it
demonstrates not only interest and
engagement it demonstrates humility so
when you ask a question you're taking a
posture of humility in what can be an
awkward conversation so i might even ask
something as you present the research
and say hey can you help me understand
why my position and my my comp does not
match what the industry standard is or
what the comps are out there or the
value that i bring based on my
production all your employer cares about
is market
uh what's what's comp in the market and
what value you're bringing they don't
care what you need so we're going to
focus on the facts like ken said of
what's standard in the market and what
you bring to it but you can ask that as
a question like hey help me understand
help me understand why i am here and
this is what's going on there and then
and then that will lead to a great
discussion i think yeah just guard
putting them on the defensive that's
what you don't want to do and here's the
deal if you're going to go shop other
jobs and they give you an offer you
better be ready to leave because doing
that as a negotiation tactic i think is
a bad move yeah it's good you got to be
willing to go it's true so don't go in
there with a tactic and then fold
oh that'd be dangerous all right folks
don't move before you know it chrissy
wright and i will be right back this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
christy wright thrilled to have you with
us triple eight eight two five
five two two five do you feel like
you're constantly running but nothing
you do ever moves the needle in your
money in your life well that's normal
and normal is frustrating and exhausting
but you can live the life you want
when you're debt-free where you actually
have breathing room
in your time and your money but you
gotta have a game plan
and that's why we at ramsey solutions
want you to join us for game plan live
this is a free live stream on september
the 28th
dave ramsey christy wright and george
campbell will help you set the
foundation that makes all your goals
possible you don't have to settle for a
life of normal get the plan they get you
where you want to be to register
for this game changing event game plan
live text game plan to
33789 that's game plan all one word
three three
seven eight nine text
thank you for taking gamepl call you bet
what's going on today teresa
this is for you ken maybe well christy
you can jump in too i'm sure she might
appreciate
um what do you do when you're you're
calling your passion
is in a field that doesn't pay what you
need to make
to pay your monthly bills all right tell
me more what's the calling what's the
feeling okay it's it's the dogs at the
animal shelter and the humane society
i volunteer every chance i get i work
full time but
they make me so happy i mean
and i want to i want to work there but
i ask them if they have openings and
they say sure
pays ten dollars an hour
oh
okay i just wish i could be there all
the time and make a living all right so
open the dog okay i got it all right all
right chris and i are gonna put our
heads together i'm feeling pretty
confident we can come up with something
but i need to know what is make a living
give me a number
what do you need to make well
right now i'm making about 34 000 a year
it's a it's a humble job and but i don't
hate it what's the job
i'm a courier i drive around all day for
a medical lab okay great um how much
research have you done
into uh the field of pet care let's just
call it pet care i know you love dogs
but there's probably some other animals
you love too yes or no
yes yeah just generally you love animals
so
yeah so what we've got to figure out
theresa is how do we
make more money than 10 an hour let's
just keep the bar really low but what if
theresa what if you stayed in this
courier job which you don't hate and
it's a pretty stable job and we could
add
maybe 10 15 000 over the next 12 months
to the 34 and you're loving on dogs how
would you feel about that if we just
added 10 to 15 000 as a side hustle
or a part-time job
to what you already make how would you
feel about that
i would be
very very happy great do you believe
that you can do that teresa yes or no be
honest
i've thought about it ken and i can't
come up with
anything and keep my full-time job
what's your hours as the courier
okay i clock in at 9 30 a.m and i get
off at 6 30 p.m
the good news is i've got christie right
next to me who is an idea factory along
with me and between the two of us it's
combustible christy i'm having a hard
time believing teresa i think there's
some side stuff on the weekend taking
care of animals checking on animals
maybe at night boarding some dogs
overnight i think there's a way for her
to get started where she may not see it
what do you think yeah it's interesting
because when you start to brainstorm
theresa how you can do
what you want to do what you're excited
about in lots of different ways then you
realize there are multiple paths to get
to this place where you're doing what
you love and making money doing it let's
just throw out
one for example one that we haven't
talked about
um what would it look like to meet your
end goal of being with animals like
ken's talking about and not necessarily
through the shelter where you started a
side business of a doggy day care of a
dog walking dog care dog whatever
there's multiple ways to look at this
for example and i remember someone
calling in the ramsay show years ago and
they said i really want to be a teacher
but i can't live on a teacher's salary
and dave said well i'm a teacher there's
a lot of ways to be a teacher you don't
have to be a teacher in a school
so just just a zoom out teresa i want
you to zoom out and i just got a
challenge for you i want you to write
down
every possible iteration every version
of ways to make money doing what you
love that do not include the shelter
some of them will be good ideas some
won't be good ideas some will make money
some won't some you could do part-time
full-time on the side
your own business working for someone
else i just want you to make a list of
as many ideas you can think of and i
guarantee you there's at least 20 ways
to be with animals
and make good money and that's just at
your first draft of this list okay so
theresa here's the deal chris is
absolutely right i need you to stop
thinking about an opportunity at the
current spca they're very limited okay
what you've got to be thinking about as
and listen i know the chattanooga area
it's a great area surrounding areas okay
now listen i don't know if you've looked
up what it costs to board a dog
but it's big dollars there are pet
hotels there there are pet stores that
may have a part-time job here's what i
want you to grasp okay i wrote a book a
couple years ago called the proximity
principle all right now here's what it
says teresa i want you to grab this in
order to do what you want to do all
right work with dogs
you got to be around people that are
doing that and in places where it is
happening
you've only been to the spca as my
colleague christy accurately pointed out
you're limiting your entire perspective
to the spca as opposed to who's making
the bucks boarding dogs
all over the greater chattanooga area
come on teresa you ought to have a list
of three to five of those before you go
to bed tonight
yes wow
yes yes i i never thought about it i
know that's why you called but listen
now now listen here's the rest of it i
also got to get around people not just
places so those are the places
but it's not enough to just get a list
of places and then start applying no no
no no no no
you want to start to ask yourself all
right now that i've got a list of five
dog hotels
whatever
oh let me tell you something theresa
don't even forget the people that come
out to your house i've got a gal that
comes out and and takes care of ellis
the golden doodle once a month and she
comes up to our door gets ellis takes
him to the van spends an hour and a half
with him and comes back in a brand new
dog she's killing it in a van
no she's not killing the dog right and
she's not in a van down by the river
either right she's really she's really
killing it so here's the deal
i want you to think about who do i know
teresa i want you to ask this question
after you get your list of three to five
maybe seven
i want you to think who do i know in my
life that's close personal connections
uh family friends now let's go
acquaintances my kids play soccer my
kids do this my kids do that i go to
church with these people i'm over here
in the bunko club what it is everybody i
know do they do those people know
anybody that works at any of those
organizations
now
we begin to dial in oh you know somebody
over there yeah i know somebody over at
paws and claws great can i have coffee
with them yeah i'll set it up for you
and the next thing you know you're
meeting people that are working in that
space and so now theresa you're top of
mind the first time they have a college
kid quit on them and they need somebody
to pick up 20 hours your answer right
now is abso freaking legally i'll be
there
and now theresa here's the path i get in
i get in
and then i think about moving up but see
you're trying you're treating this whole
transition as an all or nothing i'm
leaving courier to go full-time dogs and
that's rarely how it happens so i hope
that encourages you you know exactly
what to do now there's no excuse let's
listen to both of our books we'll send
you proximity principle and business
boutique and and ken's going to help you
exactly what he said in proximity
principle being in the places and it's
very nice and then business boutique if
you just started start a side gig doing
this business boutique will be the plan
you'll have both will come from from
both i gotta add one thing okay
she needs your new book take back your
time because what what we just
prescribed to her is a lot of work she's
gonna she's gonna feel a little frazzled
she's gonna need some time
send her all the things theresa you're
getting a whole bunch of things you're
getting a sweet business boutique case
you want to start that doggy daycare on
the side christy will tell you how take
back your time this will help you stay
sane in the midst of this hustle season
and then the proximity principle the
ultimate secret to connections which
lead to opportunities there you go oh my
goodness folks this is why you call the
show you never know how much free
goodies you're gonna get we i mean we
just we love giving away dave's stuff we
do we're very generous with this thing
yeah very i have a spiritual gift of
giving away all the ramsay solutions
resources all right don't move more of
the ramsey show coming up just around
the corner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague christy wright
today's a big day for christy and for
the entire company because her latest
book take back your time the guilt-free
guide two
life balance is out everywhere books are
sold ramsay solutions.com tons of great
stuff for bundles but as she announced
earlier in the hour it's a big deal
nobody uh besides dave uh to my
knowledge has ever been in target and
she is at the old target
uh in your local neighborhood uh in cap
and everything yeah so big deal
i think it would be fun i did not talk
to christy about this ahead of time but
uh i don't need to
i think uh if you're christy wright fan
like me you know what you need to do you
got to make a trip to your local target
even if it's to get some anti-back wipes
because we always need more of those
and take a picture
beside the old end cap and uh tag
christy at
christybright yep uh on insta yes uh
that'll be fun it will be fun that would
just lift your heart wouldn't it it
would it makes it so
real man we love target i gotta get
there i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do it i gotta get out there i
don't know if it'll be tonight yeah it's
taco tuesday we have football practice
and many things sure but i'm going to
get out there by the end cap and i'm
going to post it so go to target for
your copy of the book and then just do
what you always do we just spend 200
worth of other things we don't actually
need which is what we all do or oh good
call oh you know what i just realized a
great
marketing for a toothbrush and come out
with something instead of buying all the
things you don't need there you go buy
three copies of your book okay i like i
like where your head's at ken i
appreciate it two to somebody else you
got christmas gifts i don't know just
carry them around and you see the
frazzled mom yeah guys here ma'am i
think you need yes yep
just read this
you know like it's like it's a
devotional just kind of hand it out here
just just read this there you go i think
you need this yeah fun stuff all right
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five uh
we're taking your calls on everything
money we'll take it on the life balance
and time will take it on hey uh my work
can i wanna do work that i love but also
make a bunch of money i want to make
more money i want to get that shovel
bigger so i can get out of debt faster
get through the baby steps faster we'll
take all of those calls and jason joins
us now in orlando florida jason how can
we help
hey first off it's great to talk to both
you guys how you guys doing oh we're
having a blast what's going on did you
hear that chrissy's in target jake
i don't feel like we've talked about it
enough yeah
that's all right what's going on um my
my question for you guys um we're on
baby step two we're about six months
into our journey
um my big concern is with our house
we're looking at possibly replacing the
ac unit within a year or so
so that's a cost that's going to be in
the forefront and my wife is from
england uh so we're actually planning a
trip to go next year to england for her
uh her brother's wedding
um for the three of us so that's going
to be a trip that i was going to be
going to
and my biggest question is with breaking
down to only a thousand dollars in this
emergency fund how do we plan these
trips how do we put things on pause to
plan for this vacation uh slash wedding
next year how do we plan our ac unit
hopefully i'm gonna be replaced soon uh
just makes us a little bit nervous drop
it down to only that thousand
yeah well well i understand that and
here's the way that you're gonna
approach something like an ac unit or
even obviously a family wedding which is
a really big deal is it's exactly like
you just said jason you're going to
pause
paying extra on your debts and you're
just going to stockpile cash but i do
want to encourage you just because
you're pausing the baby steps
temporarily in your stockpiling cash so
that you can cash flow your ac unit and
you can cash flow this family member's
wedding and that type of thing we're not
going to use this as an excuse to just
have a big time and spend thousands of
extra dollars on this trip just keep in
mind you're still broke you're still in
debt and i don't say that to make you
feel bad i say that to lighter fire
under you go okay how can we
get this ac unit get a really good deal
make it last as long as we can before we
replace it and so on how can we make
this trip for our family in the wedding
you know in another country on a budget
how can we be resourceful and not see
this as a vacation where we're just
going to splurge and stay at the nice
place oh we're on vacation people people
kind of lose their minds on vacation
like oh i can just money is free on
vacation and then they make dumb
decisions i just as long as you keep in
check
hey these are two necessary expenses
we're going to cash flow them so we
don't go into debt for them and we're
going to get right back on track with
baby step two whenever we cash flow them
and and by the way if you know budget
for what you need for the ac unit get
multiple quotes from vendors find a good
deal that is fair figure out your timing
of when you absolutely really need it
and then save that amount of money same
thing for the trip price that out what
are flights where are you going to stay
what do you need for that once you get
that amount of money jason you're right
back in baby step two even if you don't
need the ac unit or the um i haven't
gone on that trip for the wedding yet so
we're not gonna we're not gonna just
keep piling cash above and beyond what
we need get realistic with what you need
for both of those save that amount of
cash so you can cash flow them when they
happen and then you are right back into
baby step two and it is a small setback
from the progress on your on your baby
steps and becoming debt free but these
are necessary and that's the big
distinction that we try to help people
understand
saving for um having a baby when you're
pregnant or saving for you lost a job so
there's things that yeah you save for a
car we don't want you going to debt so
you need to stockpile some cash for
those things but just the amount that
you really need so jason i'm curious
about the health of the
hvac ac unit how bad is it has someone
looked at it and said this thing's going
to go at some point soon i'd like to
know more about this i have a method to
my madness what's this i'm curious
that's right um so we moved into the
house just over four years ago and it
was something on the inspection that was
a hey this is kind of on its way out
make sure to keep an eye on it
um and then we just had it break down
about three or four months ago and it
was a look to where um we got lucky it
was just a small clog in the drain but
the insides are broken to the point
where nobody's actually going to work on
it because they're worried about it
going to puts on
uh so nobody's going to touch it and
when it eventually goes it's going to go
uh so they expected the the device is
from like 2000 or 2002. yeah and in 40
years that's a lot of years for a unit
gotcha okay so you've done your homework
yeah so okay that's really good but
here's where i was going with this i
would go ahead and stack the money up
and go ahead and do it but i'm the guy
who tries to get the money stacked up
but still lets the sucker run until it
dies that's what we're doing replace it
now ours is going out we just keep
putting more coolant in it until it's
literally dead until like you know so
getting that thing in the parking garage
that's right so jason i just wanted to
make sure you've done your homework i
think that you've got a couple of
opinions on that so you know so my point
is while you're saving everything
chrissy said to spot on i just want you
to go sometimes these people scare us
and these home inspectors oh my goodness
i listen i know some home inspectors
they do really thorough work but their
job is to be thorough and find
everything wrong and i'm the guy who
goes okay so you're telling me this is
gonna die pretty soon yes sir mr coleman
that's what i'm telling you okay do you
have any idea when it's going to die of
course not could be six months could be
a year and a half great
so you're saying there's a chance yeah
it's so cool
i'm not replacing it until it's dead
so i'm gonna work hard to have the money
saved up that's right uh but i'm gonna
let that baby go go and go and go and go
we've we've honestly been doing that at
our house for about a year and a half
like really yeah you and matt are out
there with the old coolant and you're
just like we just keep putting
why not
i think how much does a jug of coolant
go forward
no idea but i'll tell you i think next
year's the year we really have to
replace it but it's the same concept
this is not like a uh used car where
you're like okay i want to re have some
resale value that type of strategy which
you could justify this ac unit like
you're going to run it into the ground
until it is dead and you can't even pray
it back to life and then you get a new
one like you get every mile out of it as
you get especially when you're in debt
especially when you're like i've got to
scrape by to save up this to cash flow
it you you don't let's to your point
don't let someone come and go oh you
need a new one you're like oh i got to
get a new one and then you get the
cadillac of ac you know you don't have
the money you got to be careful because
listen i i can't i'll give you a story a
a really uh recent story so we had our
air ducts cleaned all right this is a
thing you don't think about much no
let's get the air ducts i've never
thought of that oh really it's really
good it's good for you okay great yeah
uh but they'll come in until i'm at work
the guy comes does all the stuff looks
at it gives stacey a quote you know and
he's like he's got three or four things
that i've never heard of himself sure
and it sounds like if we don't do it
right you're probably gonna we're gonna
die in our sleep yeah
and it's just so extreme and so over the
top i'm like uh okay thanks uh tell you
what let me think about it so i call my
father-in-law who happens to be a home
contractor a builder yeah he's like yeah
you don't need that that that or that
yeah but the way it sounded it was as if
we were breathing in
toxic air
uh on steroids yeah so just be careful
don't let people scare you get multiple
opinions multiple quotes and then save
up for it so there you go all right hey
i want to thank our producer james
childs our associate producer and call
greater kelly daniel my colleague
christy wright congrats on launch day
take back any time the guilt-free guide
to life balance go get it everywhere
books are sold or it's your neighborhood
target but mostly we want to thank you
america we do this show for you this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life
we're talking real stories real men and
women
hopeful practical steps forward
to being and doing
who you're supposed to be what you're
supposed to do
money
work
relationships i'm ken coleman joined by
my colleague dr john delaney we are
together this hour taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so uh doc let's set the table shall
we uh we can do a little dr john dolone
show we'll talk about mental health
emotional health marriage issues we'll
talk about ooh how about this one toxic
workplace garbage oh john and i want to
crappy leaders
that are making you consider changing
your entire career lane is that
necessary
uh the emotional junk at work john and i
love to team up on that because that's
his area in the area of mental and
emotional health i'm over here in the
area of purpose and doing what you were
created to do of course we'll take your
money questions relationship questions
uh here's one
been getting a lot of traffic james the
producers telling me
uh people asking questions hey ken my
company is going to mandate the vaccine
for various reasons i don't want to do
it that means i might lose my job i'm
expecting to lose my job what do i do
i'm getting that call regularly on the
ken coleman show does that come to you
on the doctor
yeah so john and i uh can help you with
that because that is not just a that's
not a work career question that there's
there's all kinds of stuff there there's
the emotional the mental duress the
financial decisions you got to make this
is a tough choice that's being uh
brought your way so we'll take those
questions here's what we're not going to
do we're going to get into a political
argument over it we're going to help you
navigate
the future the steps ahead so we're
opening it up it's about you we're here
for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start it off
with tyler who joins us now in salt lake
city utah tyler how can we help
hey john hey ken thanks so much for
taking my question you bet what's up
um so i'm 22 years old and i'm working
full time right now and then doing
school online
and i'm at the point in school where i
should really be
deciding and locking in on a career or a
focus on what i'm setting and going into
but at this point in time i'm really
not sure
i can't really
navigate which path i like to go to go
down or what career i like to go into
so my question is how should i go about
deciding that
and then how much should i really um
allow money to influence that decision
of how much i'll be making in that
career
yeah so
money matters let me just start with
that but i would never
let the amount of money that i could
make
be the ultimate decision maker is it a
part of the decision yes
but not the ultimate decision maker and
i'll start with this tyler i can't tell
you how many phone calls i've taken on
the ken coleman show here on the ramsay
show where somebody has taken a
promotion because it was a lot of money
and it was a big bump and then they got
over there and they realized man i'm
miserable
and that happens all the time the data
that's out there on wall street
millionaires that are really good at
their job and making a killing and
they're miserable and as a result
they're moving into depression
they're moving into addiction all kinds
of i'm going to tell you something you
got to love the work or at some point
if you don't love your day job you
better have a side job or a hobby that's
very very meaningful to you you got to
have some purpose in what you're
contributing so uh i would consider what
your options are from a pay standpoint
but never let it be the deciding factor
so let's get practical uh you're in
school you're in a major i'm guessing
you have a couple of ideas as it relates
to paths that you're considering
what are those give me that give me the
ones that are the the most exciting to
you right now you spend the most time
thinking about
um well something in the in the business
realm um whether that's starting a
company or
or
my
girlfriend's father is an accountant so
something around that
that area doesn't sound super exciting
but something that i potentially might
be going into but
like i said i'm still kind of trying to
decipher oh yeah i get it but tyler i
gotta ask you
why did you go into school what was
something that you thought you know what
this could be exciting work has there
ever been a point where you said you
know what as i look to my future and i
wonder a little bit what did you wonder
about
what have you won
well i was originally going into school
for
psychology to be i want to be a
counselor like a therapist why because i
do love the
love to help people and i'm pretty good
at listening and um
and try and give them good advice or
help them understand their situation
better have you moved on from that
um
i think the i only did because the
school down the road kind of the extra
school kind of threw me off yeah but
hold on a second let's pause that
what was the driving
reason behind your interest in
psychology and helping people
specifically the problems that people
have that draw you in
that led you that direction anything
from your personal journey or
observation experience
yeah i would say probably experience
are you comfortable sharing that
um yeah so i
i actually um
my mom had me see a counselor growing up
just with
family matters with um
siblings and family in and out of
different
treatment centers and everything yeah
and i think just having as a child
growing up having someone to
talk to and
not only to listen to you but to you
know help you navigate um through you
know whatever craziness you're going
through yeah you had somebody in that
role that still means a lot to you
yeah yeah definitely so let me
oversimplify this
if i could fast forward the schooling
necessary to be a professional licensed
counselor i want john to jump in here
that's his training but if i could fast
forward that process
money
time you didn't have to go into debt to
do it
how
high up the ladder would that be as your
choice would you even be calling me
right now
yeah um definitely not you wouldn't be
calling
no why
um because i think
that
that ending destination point is um you
know ultimately where i want to be and i
think it's the the journey
the long journey together is kind of
well all right so i want to turn it over
to my colleague who knows a little
something about the journey and john you
can you can steer him there it's not as
long and not as expensive as he thinks
how old are you man
i'm 22. so here's the question you have
to ask yourself
when i'm 27 which you're going to be
do you want to be 27 and working for
your father-in-law as a miserable
accountant
or do you want to be a licensed
counselor
because you're going to be 27 either way
and you're either going to take a
journey here's what you have to do you
have to choose your heart
do you want to choose a challenging and
i hope it is rigorous and challenging i
want counselors that are well trained
it's going to be challenging it's going
to be hard it's going to push you and
you're going to accomplish it and you're
going to achieve it because you love it
or
do you want the heart of working for
your father-in-law
moving spreadsheets around and watching
your soul be sucked out of your chest
into the spreadsheet you're looking at
go to school for what you want to do and
go help a whole community of people yes
get better we need you man tyler you
said if you knew you could do it quickly
and easily you wouldn't even have called
us go do what your heart is pounding for
you to do and hang on the line kelly
let's give him a copy of debt free
degree let's give him some resources to
show him how he can get that counseling
degree do with the cash flow without
debt and help people that are hurting
love you tyler this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony we're taking your calls about
money we're taking your calls about your
work hey you want to make more money you
want to move john this is very
interesting um
i'll share this a little bit later i'll
tell you what i'll tease this james i'm
going to pull it up and then the corners
are right
coming up i'm going to give you some new
data about how many americans is going
to blow your mind are actually
considering changing jobs it's a
striking number i'll just tease that and
leave it alone and uh we'll get to that
and hey it's fascinating we're going to
talk about it on the back end of that
there's some really
important psychology on the back of it
yeah i want to talk about let's get into
that that'll be that'll be good i'm
really excited to get your take on it i
mean because here's what i can tell you
the pandemic has led to all of this
it's it's i can't wait for you to just
shook the snow globe well the numbers
have expanded dramatically from where
they've been for probably the better
part of a decade so we'll get to that
cool uh that's gonna be a fun
conversation so we'll take your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey you got some relationship stuff
uh some mental emotional health i mean
how many out there
have just been
burning at both ends and you feel like
you got nothing left in the tank or you
feel like you and your
spouse are great co-managers ooh i like
this one but the spark has left the
building how about the co-worker that
has got you to the point where you feel
like you can't come back into the office
yeah stealing your joy that's how i feel
when it when you're with me that's right
yeah all right so john and i are going
to actually talk about it together
that's also going to be we're going to
have a relational debrief here
uh we'll take those calls so we'd be
thrilled to talk with you triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to drew now in monterey california
drew you're on the excuse me jeez
there's a freudian slip i've done that
before have you done that yet it's not
freudian but it's not freudian what is
that slip just
your habit yeah yeah yeah you're on the
ramsay show there you go the actual show
we're on today drew how can i help
how you guys doing we're doing good
what's up
um i'm just wondering how i should
determine how much i should take a
position for
there's a 20 000 gap just say like
50 to 70 a year or 60 to 80. and i'm
just trying to determine how much i
should ask for
well give me a little okay so i heard
the 50 to 70 and the 60 to 80.
help me out a little bit more have you
actually been offered the position
um well it's just a few positions i'm
trying to figure out which one i'm going
to take but it's my
dilemma is just uh
taking a number i guess when they really
ask
something that's going to
benefit me because it's a 20 minute
drive and it's
i work in agriculture so there's usually
overtime and gotcha a long day so i'm
just trying to wonder how much okay so
i'm very young i'm out of college so
okay and and one more quick question and
i'm going to give you something to think
through
are all these positions that you're
applying for are you actively applying
are you just considering have some of
these been offered what's the status
that you're looking at um actively
applying and i have two offers right now
okay so let's talk in terms of the two
offers are both of those two offers are
they are very similar position
yeah okay great have you done your
homework it sounds like you have uh on
the range of salary for somebody of your
experience in those
jobs um yeah i have it's kind of tough
uh
because some people get paid that with
no experience i mean no education just
experience right and you've got some
education
yeah i want to say it's somewhere in
between but okay so let's just give me
the number that it's in between give me
a give me a range
okay 50 to 70. so i'm thinking like i
would really like to get 65 knowing it's
like i'm gonna have to do some overtime
and got it okay yes okay so here's how
we simplify this if your goal is 65
you'd be really happy with 65.
so what we look at as we go up go ahead
yeah go no no go ahead sorry well if
we're going to be really pleased with 65
and you would be happy with 65 yes
um i mean i'd really be happy with 80. i
mean the more money the better yeah you
would drew we got to deal in reality
young man okay you're really really
young so let me put this a different way
if the range is 50 to 70 and you're
straight out of college with very little
experience
you need to be realistic
yeah yeah i have four years though four
years i'm sorry position
yeah i'm sorry too i lift some stuff up
the position requires like a couple
things i don't have like spanish and uh
really that's it okay well hold on a
second brother if it requires spanish
and you don't have it how are we gonna
get the gig
how have they offered it
well
like
i usually have no problem communicating
with uh people who speak speak spanish
i'm i know a little bit of spanish i'm
not fluent though okay drew i wouldn't
hire you just so you know you'd come ask
for money and i would say yeah i'm so
confused as to how you got offered the
job when they're requiring spanish i so
let's just start it here's the general
advice for anybody who is looking at a
range of salary let's just keep it
simple all right
when there's a range 50 to 70. and i
love this as a real life example
you've got to look at the data out there
that shows
what the average is for somebody of your
experience you said four years i believe
so you want to look at that and let's
just say that that's in the 58 to 60
range
i think i think you could go a little
bit above that in the asking but i
wouldn't go much right because i think
if you do that um you're you're running
the risk of missing a really good
opportunity and when you're young and it
sounds like he is
i didn't get into the family
responsibilities but i'm looking at the
number that for me is
bottom basement where i'm going to feel
yucky if i'm being realistic
there's the big asterisk john gotta be
realistic i'm young four and four years
into the world okay but i've got this
number where i go that's going to feel
bad so i'm not going to do that but i'm
also not going to give them this high
number
so whatever that number is you got to
decide on this is my walk away number
and then you can go a little bit above
that don't go to the high range because
if you're looking at the range 50 to 70
and you've looked up in the evidence
says it's about 58 is what people are
making don't ask for 65 right i'm okay
with 60.
well in some of those ranges
are a range
that's the whole point yeah john i love
the law of averages there's something
there well and
my tendency is i see 50 to 70 and i
think you know what i am ken i'm a
snowflake
i probably deserve 75. and that's what
he said basically and then i spend it in
my head yeah and then they come in and
offer me 56 which is a stretch for them
yeah and i feel like you're ripping me
off right and by the way the 56 is right
in line yeah so you've got here's the
point do your homework on what the real
averages are
for somebody that has your level of
experience and what about the other side
where
you got to know how much money you need
to bring in as well well there's no
question that's what i'm saying the
first thing we do before we ever do and
can i take this job before we ever do
our range research we basically say this
is the bottom level so for you and i
we've got a wife and kids
you and i've got a number we're going no
matter what we're doing this is the
number i gotta make and so we start
there yeah and so a young man like this
who wants to go into this kind of field
and he's got all these different options
you don't have to take your first option
either but don't price yourself out now
what's interesting john about this
particular job market and i know you've
read this
but we we are in a place where we've got
10.4 million jobs available now that's
the whole gamut so not all of those are
great jobs let's put the asterisk out on
that
8.3 million people unemployed
uh the federal unemployment insurance
benefit ran out in the 26 remaining
states that we're offering it on labor
day so we will see where we are in
another month with the jobs report but
there is still a white hot opportunity
in a lot of places where companies are
offering college tuition part full-time
signing bonuses so the point is doing
your research and seeing the range of
what's available but then not
overselling don't overshoot what could
be a massive opportunity to get in
especially
for three thousand dollars or yeah
especially
and man i don't mean to ruffle feathers
but kind of i do
especially for your ego
if you are
you've been working for four years and
you have your degree and you look at
somebody and say
i gotta even have a degree i should be
making way more yeah that's ego that's
ego that's right you don't know how
they're connected what kind of skill set
et cetera et cetera so yeah get in there
get your job man and then work real hard
and be
be really
um fun and encouraging to be around and
you're not gonna have to worry about
money for very long yeah that's
absolutely right you know there's this
something about youth and it's awesome
yeah the expectancy she's gonna be
careful that expectancy doesn't we gotta
we had a job where
it requires spanish i can i can i can do
that good i can uh i can communicate do
you know spanish are you fluent no but
i'm able to uh communicate with uh
colored pencils and paper
what
i don't know i don't know interesting
stuff all right folks don't go anywhere
he is dr john delaney i'm ken coleman
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
daloni we're taking your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five how many times in the past year
have you heard someone say
i just wish things would get back to
normal but what was normal like for you
were you worried about money
too much to do not enough time to do it
you shouldn't have to go back to that
when there's so much better ahead
but in order to do that you need the
right game plan so we want you to join
us for game plan live
this is our free live stream on tuesday
september the 28th dave ramsey christy
wright and george campbell will be
laying out the clear plan
to make all of your money goals happen
like how to find a vision that gets you
excited how to set healthy boundaries
that keep you focused you can have the
abundant balanced debt-free life you
want and it all starts at game plan live
to register for this free live stream
event text the word game plan to three
three
seven eight nine that's game plan all
one word
text that word game plan to three three
seven eight nine triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh john i wanna
take this i wanna take a quick snapshot
of where we sit right now we're
obviously in a very interesting time
uh in in the american workplace and
quick context
we spend the average american does 90
000 hours
at work in our lifetime so if you take
sleep
and work
that's basically it you got a little bit
of time to squeeze in the family right
and sporting events and all the things
the hobbies the music and all the things
it's amazing
uh and so there's a recent story here on
cnbc uh i talked about this yesterday on
the ken coleman show they're calling the
economists are calling this year of 2021
the great resignation what do they mean
by that
the amount of people that are
considering and actually leaving their
positions to go do something else to go
do something else here's the back story
couple i'm just going to hit a couple of
things here and then i want to dive in a
couple questions here
um
money penny did this report uh they
found that a whopping 93 of americans
said they aren't currently pursuing a
dream career the american dream
fascinating a lot there very interesting
stat then
sixty percent of people are rethinking
their career
um
one in three are actually considering
leaving their job so you got job then
people leaving totally different career
paths
and
the statement made about the study is
there's a crisis of identity yep
and uh listen to this one last piece of
data as many as 95 percent of workers
would consider uh the job change and 92
are willing to switch industry so
there's all this willingness considering
all these different numbers coming out
bottom line is
um you and i were talking about this
during the break
uh i'm the guy that's always preaching
purpose you were created to fill a
unique role in your work
you were needed you must do it but a
role speaks to could be multiple jobs
multiple career paths as long as you're
using your talent to do work you love
passion to produce results that there's
some deep meaning in the results when i
hear these
stats
i wonder how much of this is poor
leadership
one-on-one relationship with a leader in
somebody just awful leadership that you
and i know there's a massive leadership
crisis
i wonder how much of this is
overall cultures that have been affected
by the pandemic changes there's some
leadership implications there as well
i wonder how much of this is you know
what
i saw a lot of people die
i saw massive change in my own life
and i now want to embrace
the rest of the change that i was
previously unwilling to change because i
see how precious life is i see
how much it really matters to me to do
something i love i mean there's a lot
there i'm trying to give you the
cornucopia of what i think is going on
and then one of the when you look at
depression look at anxiety you look at
any number of psychiatric disorders and
one of the cornerstones of of
your body starting to res
take on some of these things is a lack
of control
and
i think there's been a pervasive
rightly or wrongly that's a whole other
show
a pervasive sense of
oh i just thought that
things were going to be okay i thought
there was somebody driving i thought
that my
doctors would all have the same answers
i thought my churches would all have the
same answers i thought my i didn't
realize my workplace would just oh
you're gonna send me home oh i'm on the
cut list and i think you're watching
the country in mass
open your eyes and say i have to be the
same as dave's been teaching for years
you have to be responsible for your
money you got to know where it's going i
think people are starting to say
oh i have a role to play in
what my day-to-day is going to look like
what my family lives can look like where
i'm going to live what my work is going
to be i'm just going to blindly accept a
job what my health is gonna be you me
i'm getting more questions about
relationships and what should i be
eating and what's exercise look just
these basic things that we just put on
autopilot for the last 100 years and
people are saying well i got to take an
ownership role in this yeah and this
idea that you just got to be in your job
for the rest of your life because i just
do marketing this is what i do now
people are saying
i'll do it i'll do something else where
i've got some more autonomy and control
and peace and then i feel like i'm
contributing yeah i i want to know what
you think about this i've been i spent a
lot of time thinking about this and i
think the american dream somewhere along
the line whatever that is right but
it's really not the american dream it's
the human dream but i think in modern
times john i feel like the human dream
the american dream
i think it's been
taken hostage and it's turned into a
pursuit of stuff
it's status yeah and i think what the
pandemic helped usher in
is nothing new
that people in mass are going huh it's
not about stuff i was working for stuff
and maybe some status yeah
i kind of now want to work for
significance what matters to me so if it
is working from home because i get to
see my kids more than i've ever seen
them you know what i mean i mean
whatever the circumstances
uh i think that's the shift yeah i think
it's significance even what matters to
me
yeah that phrase pursuit of happiness as
though it's out there and i just gotta
go get it versus right i'm gonna decide
to be present and whole wherever i am
and then
i you know
that car is not gonna complete me that
job title isn't going to make me go ah
after years of trauma and
heartbreak now i'm good because i'm an
assistant vice president that's not how
that works no the golf club membership
isn't it i think it's about contribution
yeah and i and well i don't think i know
yeah it's interesting to bring up thomas
jefferson's words the pursuit of
happiness that we kind of all said in
the fourth grade or whatever grade you
remember saying it in the declaration of
independence but he was interested he
was really influenced by john locke one
of the great thinkers of all time i'm
not going to nerd out and lose all the
audience but i would ask you to go look
into some of those folks from the
enlightenment how they really shaped
jefferson's words and you touched on it
the pursuit of happiness wasn't about
stuff and status
it was about what mattered to you what
was your contribution that's why i wrote
the new book from paycheck to purpose
we're talking about stop thinking about
all of your worth and all of your
success tied to your paycheck
i mean we need a paycheck we need
provision no one's dishonoring work here
at ramsey solutions we believe in it
absolutely okay what i am saying is i
think that's one of the big shifts i
think people have been forced to
confront
life
and the reality of their contribution
and what matters most your thoughts on
that yeah a hundred percent and i think
the amount of collective trauma we've
experienced over the last 18 24 months
the the collective confusion the
collective
disorientation yeah
um i i always go back to neuroscience
and
man we've got some very primitive
responses which is we're gonna fight it
we're gonna scream and we're gonna yell
and we're gonna
like
throw stuff at each other
and then we're going to run the great
resolution great resignation i think
that
i'm going to be better over here than i
am right here and some of that's true
some of that there's toxic you've been
putting up in toxic environments crappy
leaders for years
the other side of this i always want
people to slow down for a second because
man i've said this on the show a number
of times wherever you go
you go with you yep and if you're not
well if you're not whole if you don't
have good relationships if you don't
have purpose in what you're doing every
day
internally you're just going to get that
fancy new job and that fancy new town
and that new house and you're going to
look in the mirror that's exactly right
listen to what he's saying folks don't
jump make sure you know
what you're leaning towards folks my
brand new book from paycheck to purpose
the seven stages that will lead you to
work you love work that you were created
to do it's available for pre-order
ramsay solutions.com we got all kind of
goodies to pre-order it now i'm telling
you
you got to be clear before you make any
kind of major move like this dr john
bologna is absolutely right all right
good stuff doc coming up more of your
questions phone lines are lighting up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions worldwide headquarters
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney the phone number to jump
in on the conversation today is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
taking your questions about life every
area you got a question we're gonna do
our best to help you out john joins us
now in tucson arizona john you're on the
ramsay show how can we help
hi thanks for taking your call uh we
wanted to ask uh how can we be
fair with our three children in regard
to their inheritance in the future and
yet safeguard our one son against being
irresponsible and spending his portion
all at once or don't we treat them all
the same we don't want his inheritance
to be a curse talk about the issues that
this son's dealing with what are we
worried about
uh
he's um he has a history of substance
abuse
and he is
very irresponsible with money he's
constantly
refinancing his very old car so he can
have more money to spend he doesn't pay
his rent his landlord lets him coast
that kind of stuff
what have your conversations been like
with him
um
not very pointed because he gets all
depressed
what is that what happens when he gets
depressed
uh it's a poor me
um uh i'll never i'll never get better
i'll never amount to anything
i'm worthless
yeah he just shuts down is that a
tactic or is
is he's got some diagnosable mental
illness he's got some challenges he's
worked with yeah through his whole life
yeah he has he has a diagnosis of
bipolar okay sort of and he doesn't take
his meds okay
um
so i've worked with folks who are
prepping wills and having these
broader conversations
you know dave has is um
actually made this will and so what i've
seen folks where hey here's my fortune
that's going to go to my kids in this
way
and here's my stipulations for it
um
what i would tell you is is you and do
you have a spouse too
yeah she's sitting right here okay um i
think
backing out of the whole
this particular issue because what
you're going to do is you're going to
try to reverse engineer it and not make
an um
what you believe is not a poor choice on
this one
part of your will
and i want you to take a much bigger
picture view of it first and that is
going to be
what do we want how do we want to
steward the money that we have the money
that we've steward what do we want it to
look like when we're gone
and we want to bless our kids with homes
we want to bless our kids with fortune
do we want to give it away to charity
what are we going to do with that i want
you and your wife to have that
conversation it's a values conversation
then the second part of it is who's
going to be the executor and if you have
one child that you're going to call and
say we're
oh this isn't a call this is an
in-person conversation here's what this
looks like i'm going to walk you through
my will but it's a very detailed
conversation we are asking you to do
this
and then i think the third thing is
not avoiding hard conversations
and not avoiding stipulations that you
want to put on these these hard
conversations because it's your money
and so
if it is going to go into a trust and
you're gonna give one of your children
or two of your children
guardianship of that trust and they're
gonna dole out x number of dollars a
year if everybody is
healthy if everybody's continuing to
invest in their
relationships and their whatever you
want to look like if people aren't using
drugs if they're not addicts if you're
not going to enable them and whatever
you want to do with that money
um but it's setting it up in the trust
and the key here is you are open and
honest with all of your kids
because what you don't want to do is
dump this on your executor and let them
have the hard conversations and deal
with the relational ramifications of
letting your wishes come true
and that younger sibling is going to
hate them
and so it would be a hard conversation
that you all need to have and that's
just part of this you're you're the
parent here
i would also
say this
the tendency is is to wring your hands
and try to control things from the grave
if you will
at some point you set up a trust you set
up the values you have an executor and
you say here's our wishes for this money
and then you have to open your hands and
be at peace right
and um if you're
you set things up in a way that's gonna
at the end of the day you might not be
able to protect your son
as much as you think you're trying to
right
yeah um how much money are we talking
about here
well it's probably
um
three hundred thousand dollars for each
for each okay yeah it's a substantial
sum of money right it is yeah
um we want to be good stewards i think i
heard dave say one time
uh do your given when you're living so
you're knowing where it's going yes
there you go well john you know dave has
said this multiple times and john just
laid it out for you but i just reiterate
very quickly
you've got to lay out the morality
clauses the stuff that you're saying son
in order for you to have access to this
300k
this is what your life has got to be
like you can't have this this and this
and and it's very possible that he
straightens up right and meets those
conditions long after you're gone and
gets it but then could fall backwards
and you know so at some point i really
love what uh doc told you um you gotta
have peace but i would just set it out
there lay it very clearly out there he's
gonna have an opportunity to respond but
it is what it is it's set in stone it's
done and then you got to let it go
here's
everybody's got different approach to
this conversation the end result is is
you want people you don't want your
money to be used to hurt people
especially those that you love right and
if you hand an addict 300 000 the
chances that could go sideways are great
i love a in-person conversation way
upstream which might be
i want to see two years of you taking
your medication and i want to see two
years of you going to counseling in fact
we're going to start helping with some
of that right now
and that is going to inform how we do
great i love that right that's different
than if you ever use drugs you're out of
here i want to demonstrate and there's
there's that conversation too but i want
to invest in the wellness i think it's
both hand it absolutely here's what
we're going to do
yeah
we're going to but i've got this in
place for your brother and sister too
that's exactly we're having a
conversation with everybody that's right
so i'm with you there but yeah set up a
trust and you get to set up the details
of the trust and then get the executive
that you can lean on and if you don't
want to use one of your kids get a
family member or an attorney somebody
that you that you trust uh no pun
intended and just make sure everybody's
on the same page don't have hidden
surprises um once you pass away but
thanks for being attention with your
money yeah thanks for the call too
you're good man way to go um john i this
is so heavy i i
i shouldn't even ask it but but i know
you can handle the short version of it
it's really really difficult
for a parent who's worried about a
child's future behavior current behavior
whatever you get to the point where
you've done everything
what's the biggest i guess what's the
biggest impediment to peace uh outside
of again
the spiritual
you know conversation what's the
emotional the biggest emotional hurdle
to truly letting go and going i've done
everything they can do the kid's going
to have to stand up and fly right
the one is guilt
you did something wrong there's i should
have done this one conversation that one
time a little bit different or
um that kid's got my genetics and so
it's my fault that whatever the line is
so i should have put them in a different
school if i just worked less or worked
more and so
there's always trying to go back and
edit that sentence that's got a period
at the end of it the other side of it is
you love that kid and nobody wants to
see their kid hurt no and or stand by
and watch it oh man
and
as a parents we want to lean in and
fight the fights for them we want to
take those blows for them right i want
to run the races for them i want to do
their math homework for them because i
don't want to have to feel that and at
the same time
that's the only
way to growth that's the only way that
they can learn the skills that they're
going to need to navigate this mess of
the world so bottom line is there's
guilt and then there's just the parental
i love it's just love just rather die a
million deaths don't want your kid hurt
that's right it is
and they didn't tell us that
no when they sent us home from the
hospital i know the nurse didn't give me
the manual they said good luck with this
oh um it's a cute kid you got there good
luck it's so so hard
but it may be the best thing for them
and at that point it's like i i just
know they're parents that are listening
right now they feel like they're their
wits end well and what i see some
parents do is they take their hands off
the wheel yeah and they say best of luck
to you and then some hold that wheel so
tight too tight and that nobody can
breathe what's the analogy for the
middle grounder
find some people that you love man and
you could say this is hard and you can
weep together that's good i mean
just get up don't stop loving that's
right great stuff he is dr john dolone
i'm ken coleman i want to say a big
thanks to our producer james child and
our associate producer kelly daniel and
you america thank you for listening this
is your show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where americans hang out to
have a conversation about life we'll
talk about money we'll talk about your
relationships mental health emotional
health we'll talk about
your job your work are you on purpose
we talk about it all we'll talk about
you triple eight eight two five five two
two five is the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm ken coleman joined by dr john delony
and we are taking your calls this hour
uh john uh we were just talking to the
break fascinating with all these people
wanting to move and change jobs the
great resignation you were talking about
fight or flight big big warning sign
don't jump just because you feel or
you're thinking and you're stressed out
you're going ah i need change
slow down you say yeah so when you're
faced with chaos you're faced with fear
you're faced with
when your alarms start ringing that
you're not safe
you don't know what's coming
man there's some
we're running on ancient operating
systems up top right and so it's
our brains are gonna try to fight
something and we've seen that for the
last 24 36 months everybody yelling at
each other and screaming and hollering
and
whatever
and then
you're gonna run from it you're gonna
flee and so if you're sitting in your
job right now and you're thinking i
gotta get out of here i gotta go i gotta
go i don't have any other plans i've got
50 000 student loan debt but i just got
i can't be here if you're in an abusive
situation absolutely you got to go yeah
if you think that simply moving is gonna
solve this
i want everyone to remember that
wherever you go
you go with you that's right and then
the next you're gonna
freeze yep is that state of i'm frozen
yeah right well that sounded dumb like
that freeze is frozen right that was
stupid it was redundant but it's this
it's taking all of your feelings and
what you just shutting it down your body
just says hey we're going into neutral
here because we can't handle this and
that's next so
everybody slow down yep slow down and
that's what i love what you teach
get clear about what you're looking for
go towards something not away from
something that's it and be clear about
what you're looking for where you want
to go i think the last 24 months is
shaking our snow globe collectively
uh and individually relationally
everything and now it's a good moment in
history to ask who do i want to be what
i want to be yes right but don't make
the jump the change
without purpose being in the equation
yeah is it on purpose so you jump off
the door no you say before you jump off
the dock make sure there's a boat there
oh yeah yeah you know jumping is
overrated
it's kind of fun it's fun for fun but i
mean not big big big life changes
there's a cost there's yeah so let's be
careful we can walk into it my point is
we've romanticized the big i'm leaving
you know the jerry maguire moment who's
coming with me he's got the goldfish
yeah yeah let's not do that all right
let's get to your calls randy joins us
in roanoke virginia randy how can we
help
hey how are you guys
i'm doing great so uh
i own a couple of small businesses and i
still work a full-time job and me and my
wife had talked about it and we have
come to the conclusion that it's time
for me to jump ship
and do um my thing
and i called to get one extra opinion
but it sounds like i'm gonna get two so
uh
ken's smarter than me i may be quiet on
this one this is what this is this is
his world yeah so it sounds like you
guys have decided and you just want uh
two opinions we'll give them to you so
what are you concerned about sounds like
you've decided to jump but you're going
all right i just want to make sure this
isn't wacky so what are you afraid of
well i you know i've got i've got uh my
retirement set i'm 49 years old i've got
about 550 000 in a raw 401k nice uh
we've saved about two hundred thousand
dollars cash nice and everything we own
is paid for
um
and so you're a millionaire brother
uh yes sir um
and i
i can replace my income uh probably uh
probably
40 to 50 percent higher than i wanted
than what i make at my job
um
but i but i am leaving you know eighty
thousand dollars behind
uh so
you know there's a fear of them am i
really doing the right thing
um
and i've been able for ten years to do
this
so should i should i really leave okay
it's just explain one number to me
what do you mean when you say you're
leaving 80 000 behind you mean the
difference between what you're making
now with these side businesses
versus what your day job's paying you is
that what you mean yes yes sir i
i i don't even think this is a matt
normally to me it's always a math number
when i get this call on the ken coleman
show some people say ken is when's the
time to leave i'll go when the math is
right
when you can move
full time into your business
and the budget's stable we're not
struggling we're not scared out of our
minds because we know it's risky it's
just the right time i think that time is
already here and i think you know that i
don't think you're doing anything wrong
by leaving the day job no i do not i
think that financially you're in great
shape you have no debt anywhere in your
life and you're going to make a big
chunk of what you're already making and
you have enough to live on and i s i
would ask you this how long do you think
which and this is an estimate i know but
how long would you estimate before you
replace that eighty thousand dollars
because you're going full time into your
own business yeah i thought you said
you're going to be making more over time
i will be making more than i make uh
i would suspect that my businesses will
probably do 20 to 30 more immediately
with me just being there
and being involved with them on a
day-to-day basis so it's a no-brainer so
this isn't a math problem this is a
security blanket pacifier question yeah
yeah you're probably right yeah just
you're scared of a monster under the bed
that doesn't exist the monsters
[Laughter]
yeah well randy
i will give you a hug i actually you
know what i think randy needs i think he
needs a high five
he's crushed it
randy you're debt free you're a
millionaire you're a baby steps
millionaire you have built these
businesses up on your own i mean dude
you're where everybody wants to be
uh
walk today
you get to say take this job and shove
it and i'm gonna go make more money yes
so what what do you need from us you are
already know this
validation well you know i really like
what i do
uh but there are opportunities outside
of that to do
the works and i think i called on the
right day
because
you know there are things that i would
like to do
i just needed somebody else to say yeah
you guys are going in the right
direction uh because there's all kinds
of ministry opportunities that we can
pursue
without having this
leash on me there is no move you can
make staying or going that's not going
to have a risk to it yep
when and so whenever i look at risk i
look at what am i anchored to what am i
chained to and what is the
potential catastrophe here
and you owe nobody anything yes you've
got half a million dollars in tax free
retirement income you have a paid for
house so you're chained to essentially
nothing
and then you got a 200 000 cushion plus
already established businesses they're
going to go up 15 to 30 percent the day
you walk in the door
there is no catastrophe bye felicia
dude
you called for encouragement we're
trying to guilt you into this man
hang up the phone call your wife tell
her you're coming home to give her a big
smooch and a big hug
we're going to dinner and today's the
day i resign and step into the future i
have been planning and working so hard
for you're a freaking rock star right
that's randy randy everybody wants to be
like you when they grow up embrace it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman ramsey personality joined by my
colleague and fellow ramsey personality
dr john deloney we are part of the
ramsey network uh he is the host of the
dr john delaney show popular podcast and
youtube show
and i'm host of the ken coleman show i'm
not going to say that my own show is
popular but go check out both shows
we uh we do believe deeply in what we
what we do we believe we can help you so
we're both uh thrilled to be here it
just occurred to me james i was like i
got to say that nice about my pal but
i'm not going to say that about my own
show i'm john deloney hosting a
moderately successful kind of failing
podcast i uh host a very popular wildly
outrageously popular show you know it's
just like come on anyway uh we're
thrilled to be together as we sit here
today to take your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey uh
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
all right today's question comes from
robert in arizona robert says
i'm an engineer and i earn about a
hundred and ten thousand dollars a year
i'm married with three kids and we live
close to our parents we are debt free
except for our mortgage my employer
recently implemented some policies that
have very anti-biblical stances which
has made me look for another job
every company in my field is following
the same pattern so staying in the
industry isn't an option
there is a ministry that i really admire
and just for fun i sent my resume to
them because it's been a dream of mine
to work there they offered me a position
however we'd have to move away from
family to a new state and my salary
would be reduced by 45 000 a year
should i leave my career and family for
this opportunity all right uh so i love
these blinds.com questions because
they're always like a giant onion and
and we have no reason we just invent the
back story yeah yeah we get to try to
figure out what the back and forth would
be um
i don't think that uh this is your only
option right and so i start there uh
sounds like to me
that uh robert you've made the decision
there is no turning back there is
there's such a there's no situation by
which you're going to stay
uh in this particular company i would
challenge you to look industry-wide and
see if the positions that your company's
adopting truly are industry-wide so
let's at least do some homework let's
know that we know that we know now
having said that uh i think john when i
hear this question i see that there's a
very clear ending for him and he's going
okay it's time to move on i can't work
here anymore because of values issues
yeah okay
but just because you are enamored with
admire this ministry in another state
that has a job that pays you
significantly less money
doesn't mean it's the only
escape hatch right and so i want to see
you pursue other opportunities
um and and if you can quickly because i
know this offer's there uh see what else
is out there at least you may not have
offers but let's just see what's out
there here's my concern uh this is a
massive cut in pay
uh included in this
massive cut in pay and income
uh is leaving your family those are two
big hits john
uh those there's some emotional and
mental stuff that goes with those two
changes in lifestyle it's enough to
leave and cleave that has its own issues
right uh but then we're going to all of
a sudden almost cut our salary in half
if you could do it
do it yeah but i i just want to see
other options first can you take these
calls all the time yeah and i know
during the break we i was reading this
and i missed this one i read it during
the break
how often
does somebody have a dream job somewhere
or what they think is a dream job
they're in their engineering job their
actuarial job their accounting job their
management job and they have this
other
lighthouse on a hill somewhere yep
it's real easy to begin to backfill
and demonize and weaponize little things
to make them bigger to give myself
permission to go does that make sense
totally does that happen happens a lot
here's why
he's got this values disconnect with his
current company so he finds this
ministry which looks like to your point
a shining city on a hill like
they've been i've just really admired
them forever and it's my dream and he
thinks it's shangri-la right and so but
wait a second what do i teach well great
that you like that and you think they're
great is the position that you're
looking at in your sweet spot
do you have the talent to pull it off
does it allow you to use your talent
does it eighty percent of the job
include work that you really get juiced
about
does the job the results that that
particular job produce results that
matter deeply to you
if it's not yes on all three of those
things guess what that ministry that you
fell in love with that you donated to or
you watch on television can become a
place of misery in about six weeks so to
your point
just because you admire it and it aligns
with your values doesn't mean it's a
great place to work well i see this in
relationships when somebody's when
people's marriage is in a tough spot
we've all been there and then that
person at work starts paying attention
to you oh it's easy to go
wait a minute that's what i'm missing
here and it's not only that it's because
she
all right man it's yeah it's not reality
no anytime i'm gonna make a values-based
thing whether it's anti-biblical
anti-whatever and to fill in the blank
you know talk about man i'm always gonna
sit down with somebody that i trust a
mentor and say am i seeing this right
and in my life 99 of the time they said
dylan you're an idiot no no
you're not seeing that right at all
right yeah but anyway i'd sit down and
talk to somebody before i packed up and
moved properly
i i ramsay solutions.com we got the get
clear career assessment john we created
it for this reason yeah it's going to
measure talent passion mission 15-minute
online assessment here's what happens
you get a purpose statement and the
purpose statement is going to allow you
to look at opportunities like this and
truly vet it yeah
because is it on purpose or not yeah
because just because you like it
doesn't mean that that's something that
you were created to do so i'm going to
throw this back at him and go all right
you're dropping in biblical values i'm
going to tell you something i believe
you were created to fill a unique role
if this job
doesn't allow you to fill that unique
role use the god-given talent to do work
that god
just fires your soul up about because
you just love it
and it creates results that matter
deeply if it doesn't do that then don't
do it i don't care how awesome you love
it yeah and
it just doesn't matter go towards
something yeah go towards something
we've been targeting it's been a theme
yeah go towards something don't run from
yeah go towards man and
yeah anyway yeah let's get to it uh
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to tony in orlando florida
tony how can we help
greetings gentlemen greetings how are
you
i am well great how can we help
so i left my job
about the end of may um i'm working part
time barely making ends needs but i have
no idea what i want to do i have no
nothing whatsoever in sight so looking
for a full-time
salary position is been extremely
difficult yeah and i was just curious if
there is anything out there any
assessments or anything that can at
least give me focus on what i want to do
okay so tony let's let's address the
immediate um okay when we put you on
hold in a minute we're going to get you
my get clear career assessment we'll get
you a link and a code and it's our gift
to you i want you to take it and it's
going to help you see yourself as
you've never seen yourself before it's
going to give you all kinds of ideas
okay and then there'll be some follow-up
to where i can help you with that but
let's talk about the fact that you're in
a part-time job right now in the hottest
job job economy in the history of the
united states and you're barely makings
in me ends meet so here's the deal today
on this phone call we're not going to
try to figure out the dream job what we
are going to look at is talent only
now if you tony
introduced me to all the people that
know you well and i hung out with all of
them for about three days and i just
spent time with a pencil and paper and i
said tell me what tony does best they
would tell me what you're talented at
people skills hard skills soft skills
the whole nine yards character traits
everything okay
that's what i want you focused on
because those are the tools that you can
use right now to go get yourself a good
pain day job hear me say day job you
hear me
and then and then i want you to take the
get clear career assessment you can call
me on the ken coleman show we'll dive
deep with your results it's going to
show you what you're most talented at
it'll verify what your friends are going
to tell you
it's going to tell you the kind of work
you really love it's going to tell you
the results that you are driven by and
then it will show you professional
possibilities and then you can go do
research but here's what i want you to
do i want you to find five of your
closest friends and family members who
will tell you the truth and i want you
to all create a list
of what you do best
and then i want you to go look for a day
job where you know you can actually do a
really good job because you've got the
talent because we need a full-time job
for you tony we got to get stable
financially hang on the line we're going
to get you in ramsey plus as well so you
can get a budget going and begin to get
your financial life stable as we begin
to figure out what your professional
purpose looks like thank you so much for
the call you got this
so much value in you believe it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five i
am ramsey personality kevin coleman
joined by ramsey personally dr john
deloney we are here taking your calls
this hour it is a free call we'd love to
hear from you and uh doc uh i look
through the window here of the studio
and i see
someone on the debt-free
stage it is luke from albany new york
welcome sir thank you all right so uh
here to do a debt-free screen that's
right yeah it feels a little surreal
okay all right how much did you pay off
luke i paid off 34 128 dollars and 67
cents oh my goodness all the way down
this is i love that how long did it take
you it took me a year and three months a
year and three months all right and uh
what was your range of income
i started at about like 34 and then got
up to 42. okay 34 to 42 what do you do
oh you crushed this then i work at a
adult day hab program for people with
special needs so and i did that
and then i picked up part-time job and
a couple more side gigs along the way
okay nice so that's a 8 000 bump there
that gazelle intensity led you to do
that that's really awesome did you sell
some stuff that's a lot of money that's
basically your salary you paid off in
that in that that short period of time i
tried to sell some stuff on ebay and
that failed miserably so
uh
i didn't sell anything but i had just
graduated in 2019 okay so out of college
at my parents so you didn't have a lot
of expenses no you were you know
you are the dream graduate who just
sucks it up for one year does it buy a
bunch of new crap and just pays it off
good for you yeah awesome stuff what was
the debt
all student loans all student loans okay
very nice so you just got after it
you're like i don't like the sound of
this yeah
i hated it yeah so what was that moment
what led to it what's the back story to
15 months ago where you go i'm getting
out of debt
yeah well i started at my my first
full-time job in
november of 2019 and then in january i
was checking the website
for student loans to see how much i had
and
it was just
a moment where you get so angry you're
spending hundreds of dollars just the
minimum payments
back then because that was you know way
less than ramsay-ish at the moment
and uh you see how little it goes
towards principle and i just thought to
myself i can't spend
10 15 20 years
making these payments and
being a slave to these people so what'd
you do
so
at the very beginning i was resistant to
budgeting and
when my sister mentioned to me i laughed
it off
because i thought it was something that
restricted me
and i didn't know that it gave me
permission and it felt like a raise like
what you guys say
and
so
at the in january i was just throwing a
chunk of money at it every month maybe
500 600
and i didn't really have a detailed
budget and then probably towards spring
summer months i got really intense and
by then it was you know 10 percent tithe
and then 85 90 percent towards the
student loans and
i would celebrate every
a thousand dollar
celebration moment with
three dollars and 21 cents at mcdonald's
and then
just move on move on to the next friday
and uh just be expectant and be excited
to keep making progress
that's incredible i love that what an
absolute stud
how how was uh i mean at some point
maybe month seven
when you're hanging out with mom and dad
again on a friday or saturday night
that had to be a beating
even when they're like hey why don't you
go hang out with other people because
we're done talking to you like well john
you his mom and dad might be cool
probably not
they're saying
we didn't anticipate ourselves
how did you keep the drive up right
because man after a couple of months you
can white knuckle this thing for a
couple months but there had to have been
a temptation like i'm just gonna get my
own apartment i i mean i'm a slow i can
slow down a little bit but you kept
going it kept going and kept going yeah
there was there
i could have moved into an apartment
above my brother's house but
i
didn't want to move there
and then
slow down at all so
i wanted to
buckle down and
to keep me motivated i the part-time job
that i did was
overnights on the weekends so
i'd work monday through friday and then
friday and saturday night
and saturday night
right after work after the 11 30 to 8
a.m shift go to church lead worship
eat a fantastic lunch by my cool mother
very nice and then fall asleep for a
couple hours
wake up and then
do it all over again so
before we go forward there's a lot of
people that are rice and beans beans and
rice right now and they want to know for
three dollars and 21 cents what the
treat was at mcdonald's i know i want to
know what was it was it the same thing
a lot of times it was the same thing i
would get i'm a big eater so i would
you learn how to stretch those yeah i
want to know what you have i would get
three or no two mcchickens
large large dr pepper a lot of refills
and then
and then i had the the receipt yeah for
the free big mac
so
turn that in each time did the code see
all right see now listen that was his
motivation i love that right there two
mcchickens and a uh big mac for hustling
all week long i love it and this year
you're gonna be in the gym working off
last year's celebration which is gonna
be incredible yeah yeah all right no
judgment john no judgment i think that's
fantastic have you had the experience
yet have you had your paycheck deposit
into your account
and you got no bills i have yeah it felt
good huh
oh it feels great yeah because i paid
off my loans on easter sunday initially
i had planned to do it by my birthday
and then it just kept moving up and up
and so i paid off my loans and then
it is crazy because
when i
was you know baby step two i was so
intense i would wait till midnight on
friday night
instantly make my budget and then
instantly have like 900 a thousand bucks
to put towards the loans
so
now i forgot the question that's all
right hey tell folks real quick
what is the key to making it through
this debt-free journey from your
experience what's the key
one of the big things for me was
when i took the part-time job all the
exhaustion and
being tired all the time it was to have
the right perspective
and you guys gave that to me
i'm reminded of the verse you know every
good gift comes down from the father
above so even the tough shifts
they're a blessing too because they
provide the money to get out of the debt
and
the other verse no discipline
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but painful so if you're doing something
if you're in a painful process if you're
tired
that usually means you're doing the
right thing and it won't last for long
and i've experienced that too so now i
got baby step 3 completed as well
who's your biggest cheerleader
my mom and dad big cheerleaders my dad
would always send me a text when i was
going to the overnight nice proud of you
keep going
another
another you know hundred dollars off the
debt
and my mom
and is that mom with you here today in
the lobby it is okay fantastic way to go
mom yeah my mom would encourage me to
stick to the plan when i was so close
and i wanted to take money out of baby
step one yeah because i hated the debt
yeah but she told me just stick to the
plan stay in there love it
love it all right i also had
we took financial peace university at
our church i talked to my mom and dad
and then we had another couple join our
church so then they did financial peace
university and a bunch of people from
church got involved to uh the shavers so
they encouraged me in the social awesome
great community there well i gotta tell
you something we're proud of you young
man and uh the sky's the limit for you
you're off and running you're a future
millionaire you're gonna make a huge
impact uh and it's so obvious to all of
us so here we go
luke from albany new york paid off 34
000
in 15 months making 34 to 42 000
luke let's hear your debt free scream
three two one i'm debt free
how about that
quiet soft-spoken discipline luke just
went into hulk mode there's some rage in
there those two loans will bring it out
of you and all those chicken sandwiches
too
got to be some bad proteins in there i
don't know we'll check it out we'll
check out that
on the commercial break this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
doloni
thrilled to have you with us the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five today's
scripture
the fear of the lord is the beginning of
wisdom all who follow his precepts have
good understanding to him belongs
eternal praise that's psalm 111 verse
10. our quote today comes from oliver
wendell holmes it is the province of
knowledge to speak and it is the
privilege of wisdom
to listen
all right let's go to tim who joins us
on the line in boston massachusetts tim
how can we help
hello hi tim
hi thank you for your time uh well i'm
going to get straight to the point here
i am 29 years old i paid off the last of
my
four-year degree early 2020 after five
years and five months of extreme
budgeting thank you
and i'm thinking about going back to
school specifically in this case law
school and i was hoping to get opinions
okay why law school what's the what's
the reason for going
uh something i've been thinking about
doing for
five years now
um
i'm a firm believer that everybody
should advance themselves in some way
every single day mentally physically
career-wise
you name it
and i see it as an opportunity to
advance my own career build generational
wealth because my
older sister younger brother just had
their first children and uh it really
does shape your perspective on
everything
okay so hold on one second let's pause
there advance your career in what way
are you already uh considering a legal
career or is this this new idea and i'm
just gonna do it because being a lawyer
is gonna i'm just curious how it's
advancing your career what's the big
picture
i currently work in i.t okay
and uh
people i know have gone to law school
and they said it to being a lawyer's
grade a good friend of mine
works in a gigantic law firm out of
boston
and well i think you think it's a good
idea to uh advance my career because i
ironically even though i work at i.t i
have a fear that i'm going to get
replaced by a robot well hold on one
second tim uh what do you do in it
i work in the call center i do uh level
one okay um i see support do you
genuinely do you generally like it work
how much enjoyment do you have around
i.t subjects types of work have you
wondered about a an i.t career i'm just
curious
uh yes i do like what i do um
i always say i love and i hate the fact
that it's always changing yeah well five
years from now who knows what we'll be
doing because we didn't know what we
were doing five years ago absolutely
right but the chances of you being
replaced by a robot and technology are
very slim
uh i think technology is the hottest
industry there is it's an industry in
and of itself in that whether it's the
nonprofit world the ministry world the
medical world
big business whatever big education
there are technology jobs everywhere
with cyber security as the next new
frontier of threat around the world
technology's not going anywhere here's
the challenge that i have based on what
you've said so far
the only answer i've heard and you've
said it basically twice is that the
reason you're looking at a law degree
is to further your career and make more
money there's no mention of loving
litigation loving advocating for those
you know i look at a lawyer now there's
a lot of thing i've got a good friend
john and i share a very good friend
who's an employment lawyer world class
that's a path to being a judge i mean
legal counsel and being a lawyer
certainly is a lucrative career
however it's also a lot of money you
spent five years your words extreme
budgeting paying off your first degree i
hear no love of the work
but i don't want to make this too
philosophical for you here's what i want
you to do i want you to actually spend
some time with some lawyers have you had
a conversation with any actual lawyers
and talked about their day-to-day work
to where you have a pretty good idea
which direction you would go in the
legal field
yes i have actually which direction
would you go
uh i've been told that uh because of my
background in nit that ip law would be a
good direction
okay have you spent time with an ip
lawyer or two or three
no
that's what i want you to do you've got
to check this stuff out or else you're
going to get invested in something that
is very expensive and again all i'm
hearing is good career versus i hear
that you really enjoy technology and i
got to tell you i would want you to
weigh side by side with what i've
already told you to do john i'll let you
weigh in here in just a second but but
but i also want you to to look at what a
future in technology looks like what's a
ladder in technology
that
would allow you to do work you really
really love and be pretty fired up about
the results not just choosing law
because of the financial benefits tim i
i spent five years as a
senior administrator in a law school
and i've researched law student mental
health and attorney mental health and
folks who work with attorneys and here's
what i'll tell you
if you have a fire in your belly
to be a writer
if you have a fire in your belly to be a
serve
in service to the least of these in our
communities to fight to advocate
if you have a fire in your belly to put
on a suit and go to war as
um a
litigator assassin every day
that's the field for you
100 of the people that i met
and that i worked with who went to law
school
to quote unquote just make some money
were miserable
because the cost of law school not
financially
the emotional
psychological spiritual toll of law
school it is hard it re
tr it trains you how to see the world in
a different way that you can never unsee
it
ken is exactly right you've got to spend
some time with some ip lawyers and not
like i know a guy who just no go spend
some some time with some ip lawyers been
doing this for a decade
not someone who just quit being an i.t
exec and now is in
is now making some money at a big firm
in boston
go ask some folks who've been through
the ups and the downs and the massive
transitions in the legal profession over
the last few years
and also sit down and ask yourself what
do you want to do not i'm going to chase
something and invest a whole bunch more
money
so that i can
improve my career what do you want to do
man ask yourself that question yeah and
i think what's going to head this off
john tim here's the deal please do this
when you talk to lawyers that are in
that field that that particular
persuasion of law okay
you find out what a day looks like a
week and a month and a year and john
here's what you and i believe you and i
believe passionately about this that the
head and the heart work together
beautifully to give us confirmation
we make things a big giant mystery and
here's the deal you spend some time with
some lawyers that are in that ip field
and all that kind of stuff and they
start telling you all this stuff your
head's gathering information right this
wonderful beautiful brain we've got is
the world's greatest computer it sifts
information and logic kicks in and then
the heart gets all that information and
it goes ding ding ding ding ding or the
family feud x
that's why i tell you what does a day
look like right that's what i'm saying
you can't go to law school for something
if you don't uh you can yes
you shouldn't ever make a major
financial or educational commitment
without sitting with people that do what
you do that's why i wrote the proximity
principle i wanted to demystify
getting this idea in my head of how do i
get connected how do i figure it out and
and part of the proximity principle
isn't about connections it's just about
clarify verify
i got to get clear
what do you want to do and then go well
do i want to do that i think i want to
do that but then when i find out about
it i might go oh my gosh
most people have no idea
no clue what's involved how hard being a
lawyer is yeah how
what it does to your soul how what what
the actual job looks like
very people know what that's like you
gotta go talk to him gotta find out
every single student that came in to
school and said i wanna go do this
because i wanna serve here i wanna help
here i i love the fight i love the grind
i love writing
they are extraordinary i'm still in
contact with a lot of i was one this
weekend right she came to an event i did
those who just said i just want to go
get rich yep or i just want to go and
this isn't just law by the way this is
any correct any see i heard nothing in
there to say you know what i've i've
always been an advocate yeah and i want
to be a lawyer because i want to fight
for people
or i'm an incredible writer
yeah i want to just
move the hearts and minds of people i
want to mine the world for more ip stuff
yeah right that's right i didn't hear
any of that it was just oh i've seen my
friends have kids it's waking me up to
the fact i need more money
that's exactly right i appreciate the
call all right i want to thank my
colleague dr john delaney always fun
hanging out with you pal i want to thank
our producer james childs our associate
producer and call screener kelly daniel
and of course you america thank you for
listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsay show.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you